top ten list the best ways to get people
to click on your videos clickbait number
five will shock you
[Music]
most shoots the first shots always the
longest yes the first shot also be the
longest here so what's taking the time
well way to get ten guys in the costume
and we had a dress a set and that's it
happen to be on top of a big hill but
now it's time for me to start working
there's always the part I get most
nervous at the first shot doesn't go
well it's an uphill battle from there I
think we'll be good I'm most excited
actually about actually getting ready in
a position and running the first shot
and having it work out than ever I feel
like sick let's keep going
and they're just busting on some sweet
action for the rest of the day we're
going to the top it's time I got extra
weight on me that I'm going to leave
here like my keys so I'm feeling good
because my job at least on today's shoot
is to make sure that everything is where
we needed at the right time from here I
can just turn it over to Nikko he'll
direct the scene so and then you just
sleep yeah and then I just sleep in the
cave you know
[Music]
[Music]
yes today I'm a mummy a world war two
themed mummy Oh
today I am anonymous soldier zero I
don't even have a number I'm so
anonymous basically just the guy with
the camera on this I'm ambiguous a
patriot it's like if I want when
somebody watches us to be able to
imagine themselves in the position what
if you have any hands so many hands you
should be watching movies to begin with
this soldiers just died cameras moving
in looks up you see him pull your knife
you start coming at him that real Sam no
like 40 pounds of sand up a hill no we
got footage of it figure out a solution
for this and yes there's like a hundred
hundred of those burlap bags they had
him already filled but they were weighed
like 40 pounds each and we'd have to
like lug them up a mountain yeah where
can you buy hay around here kind of
thing if there's something else that's
efficient those packing peanuts would be
efficient those are expensive though I
mean there's a bunch of awesome [ __ ] I
mean that's like many sandbags worth of
stuff with the paper and the cloth
combined yeah let me ask her thank you
yeah but stuff ah this'll work man fill
it up this is actually perfect all right
nice and slow guys now look up see the
cocoa see your friend in front of you oh
alright Sam look to your left like that
gap from where you shoot them to when
you gave to them last maybe one second
you actually can I do to burst maybe oh
yeah oh yeah I'm like just as he goes
down this covering part did I see him I
get the other guy and then I run up my
homies days yeah once he goes down just
keep your gun trained and then rushing
like you're ready to finish yes and
actually beautiful he's gonna whip pan
over watch Devin crash goes into the
boxes and reach down to the camera Sam's
gonna take your hand and you're gonna
basically help him up
you're cleaning off your knife while
this is happening what's up car man
we're just doing some awesome stunts for
this awesome video this is a little
world famous Devon white otherwise known
as kid horror hi this is a world famous
daring Zeca Stickley making pretty
fingers
I said Jesse Jacobson over there say I
just take some pretty world famous to
this come around back there where's
famous deal Forbes ahh
a lot of blue karate like super here I
gotta rip take care of that pose covered
up the first shot
pretty good actually or takes in pretty
much nailed it feels pretty good I'm
feeling rested I'll be shoes now that
I'm accustomed to the rig more than
anything else it's all about muscle
memory in your neck because I'm not
looking at the screen ever I'm just
trying to train myself so I know how to
frame things
the challenging part the biggest
challenge today was how hot it was and
drink plenty of water there's gonna be
opening of the whole series like this is
the first minute whole series I am
confident that we got it you think
that's cool this is the first
first-person reg we made that has a real
microphone top-10 list the best ways to
get people to click on your videos click
paint number five will shock you alright
just kidding I'm not going to do any of
that they do want to talk to you guys
about titles and our videos and click
bite though because I've been going back
and forth and how we're going to get our
audience to grow and on a couple of the
videos we put out past few weeks
people have been too happy on the way
we've named them and how we've
approached marketing them a crazy
thumbnail and title does that mean that
we suddenly stopped putting a bunch of
effort into the edits and what we're
filming here for this channel do YouTube
environment is always changing this we
have to make sure we're always changing
with it evolving and trying to stay on
top of things we've been trying to
figure out how we're going to grow the
same an eco channel when was the last
time you shared a same an eco video it
just it doesn't happen vlogs don't
really go viral they don't get shared
the only way to really grow an audience
here on YouTube especially for a vlog
channel like this one is to have really
compelling marketing and that marketing
really boils down to your thumbnail on
your title now we've been kind of
experimenting with which way we go on
this there's the over-the-top crazy
title it's probably a little deceptive
and that didn't go over so well we tried
that there's a very straightforward
factual title but that's tricky when
you're doing like a 10-minute long vlog
and it covers eight different topics you
don't always really have something
that's a specific focus of a video but
the video itself is still good and you
still want people to watch it we're
trying to find that perfect middle
ground you know something that's
compelling something that makes you want
to watch something that feels like it
has inherent drama or grabs your
curiosity but we're trying to do it in a
way that is still truthful but fun while
still grabbing people who've never
watched your Samaniego video before and
making them go what the heck is this I
got check this out and it's worth
pointing out that even though our titles
and thumbnails may change the styles may
change the content on this channel is
going to only get better and better
that's it we love your guys's feedback
honestly reading the comments on every
single video is the best part about
making these at the end of the day we're
trying to do this get you excited about
watching these videos because we're
really excited
making them so some time has passed and
finally play my drums again and the
pinkies a little messed up it's about as
far as I can straighten it before it
hurts too much but I figured out a
little trick here I take a hair tie and
I loop it around these two fingers and
holds my pinky in place and now I can
actually play my drums again all right
what ego [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
Oh